الاتحاد الاوروبي يطالب ايران بتوضيح سبب
العثور على اثار يورانيوم عالي التخصيب
ويعتبره تطورا غير مسبوق
بعد واشنطن تحقيق الماني يكشف عن تورط
فريق كوماندوز اوكراني في تفجير نورت
والبيت الابيض يرحب باقتراح قانون يتيح
حظر تيك توك ضمن مشروع قرار يستهدف شركه
التكنولوجيا الصينيه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
اكد متحدث في مجلس محافظي الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان الاتحاد مازال ملتزما
بالاتفاق النووي مع ايران واعرب المتحدث
الاوروبي عن قلقه الشديد من العثور على
اثار يورانيوم مخصب بنسبه تقارب
84% وقال ان هذا الامر هو تطور خطير وغير
مسبوق ودع المتحدث ايران للتعاون بشكل
كامل وشفاف مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه بشان العثور على اثار يورانيوم
عالي التخصيب في احد المنشات النوويه
دعا مندوب روسيا لدى المنظمات الدوليه في
فيينا ميخائيل اوليانوس جميع المشاركين
بالمحادثات النوويه الايرانيه للعوده الى
العاصمه النمساويه من اجل احياء الاتفاق
النووي وقال اوليانو في البيان الروسي
بشان الملف الايراني امام مجلس محافظي
وكاله الدوليه انه يمكن تبديد مخاوفهم
العديد بسهوله مشترطا عوده المشاركين في
المحادثات الى فيينا من اجل وضع لمسات
الاخيره في غضون ايام قليله على مسوده
قرار بشان استعاده العمل بالاتفاق النووي
طلب جيم كبير الجمهوريين في لجنه العلقه
الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ الامريكي طالب
الولايات المتحده بالتركيز على خطه بديله
فيما يتعلق بالملف النووي الايراني
وقال ريتش عبر تويتر انما وصفها بالمغامره
النوويه الايرانيه تتطلب توبيخا صريحا من
مجلس محافظ او مجلس محافظي الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
وتهمتور الامريكي طهران بانها تتعامل بسوء
نيه
هذا هو قد انطلقت في ايران تظاهرات
لتربويين واولياء امور على ما وصف
بالهجمات الكيماويه في مدارس للطالبات
الاحتجاجات انطلقت الرخمه تجديد السلطات
قبضتها لمنع تنظيم تجمعات احتجاجيه
[موسيقى]
لا يزال الغموض سيده موقف حوادث التسمم في
ايران ضحايا دون متهم وجريمه كامله
الاركان بلا مجرم الجديد لكنه ليس مستغربا
ان تعود جميع اصابع الاتهام التي اطلقها
النظام نحوه مباشره
فعمليه التصميم المنظمه والممنهجه التي
طالت حوالي 230 مدرسه في 25 محافظه وصممت
اكثر من 5000 تلميذه هي براي مطلعين من
تخطيط داخلي منظم وليس عشوائيا
استهداف الفتيات تحديدا مؤشر ثان على تورط
النظام في الجريمه البشعه والتي وان لم
تسفر عن وفيات يرجح انها تسبب حاله ذعر
مزمنه حاله تلبي حاجه النظام بقطع راس
ثوره امراه حياه حريه التي لا تزال مشتعله
لكن العكس تماما هو ما حصل فاليوم اندلعت
احتجاجات اولياء الطالبات على ما وصف
بالهجمات الكيماويه في كل من طهران
والشيراز والاهواز ورشت وبابل وبشهر
وهمدان وزنجان واردبيل وسنندج وكرمانشاه
وكراج ومشهد
بعد ثلاثه اشهر من تسجيل اولى حالات
التسمم والتي اشتدت هذا الاسبوع تعلن
السلطات الايرانيه اليوم عن توقيف خمسه
مشتبهين دون الكشف عن هويتهم او حتى
الاعتراف بالتقصير بواجبها في حمايه
المواطنين
خارجياس
تخيل بيور زيد كناميت امنيات
يا ايها الجالسون التسمم التالي لابنائكم
والموت للنظام القاتل للاطفال شعارات اخرى
علقت وخطه على جدران المؤسسات الحكوميه
كلمات لقد صدن خارج ايران وصدمه كبيره في
المانيا ودعوه من الامم المتحده وامريكا
لاجراء تحقيق مستقل يكشف سر السم الصامت
في انحاء ايران
في حديث للعربيه شددت المتحدث باسم البيت
الابيض كارين جونبير على انه يجب الا تمر
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان التي ترتكبها طهران
ضد المتظاهرين من دون محاسبه
ايضا ان الولايات المتحده ترحب عفوا اذا
الولايات المتحده ترحب بدعوه مجلس الشيوخ
لبعثه الامم المتحده الدوليه المستقله
لتقص الحقائق بشان ايران
[موسيقى]
كشفت صحيفه ديسايت الالمانيه في تحقيق خاص
ان محققين دوليين عثروا على القارب الذي
استخدم لتفخيخه انابيب
اسفل اسفل البحر البلطيق وكان قد استاجره
شخصان اوكرانيا من شركه مقرها بولندا لكن
لم يعثر المحققون بعد على الجهه التي امرت
بتنفيذ عمليه تفجير وبحسب تحقيقات فقد نفذ
العمليه فريق كوماندوز اوكراني مؤلف من
سته اشخاص خمسه رجال وسيده نقلوا
المتفجرات على القارب وابحر من ميناء
روستوك بالمانيا في السادس من سبتمبر
الماضي
مندوب روسيا لدى الامم المتحده ان تقرير
الذي يتحدث عن تورط اوكرانيا بتفجير نوت
يبرر طلب موسكو اجراء تحقيق مستقل بهذا
الشان من جانبها قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
انه لا علاقه لكياف بتفجير خط نورس بدورها
اكدت الحكومه الالمانيه ان تحقيق المشترك
مع الدنمارك والسويد بشان تفجير نوت مستمر
ولم يصل لنتيجه بعد وذلك بعد ان تحدثت
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن تقييمه
للاستخبارات الامريكيه اشار الى ان مجموعه
اوكرانيه نفذت الهجوم على خطوط العمل
الماضي كما اشار التقرير الى انه لم يثبت
او لم يثبت بعد ما اذا كان الرئيس
الاوكراني زيلنسكي على علم بالهجوم الذي
قد يكون نفذ من مجموعه اوكرانيه
من يقف وراء تفجير خطي انابيب نور ستريم
صحيفه الالمانيه كشفت ان محققين دوليين
عثروا على القارب الذي استخدم لتفريخ
انابيب نورت ستريم وان منفذي العمليه فريق
كوماندوس اوكراني
الحكومه الالمانيه اكدت ان التحقيق
المشترك مع الدنمارك والسويد بشان تفجير
نورت ستريم مستمر ولم يصل لنتيجه بعد
صحيفه كشفت عن تقييم للاستخبارات
الامريكيه اشاره الى ان مجموعه اوكرانيه
نفذت الهجوم على خطوط نورت ستريم العام
الماضي
التقرير الذي يتحدث عن تورط اوكرانيا
بالتفجير نوتس ريم يبرر طلب موسكو اجراء
تحقيق مستقل بهذا الشان هذا ما قاله مندوب
روسيا الدائم لدى الامم المتحده فسيلين
من جانبها اعلنت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
انكياز غير متورطه على الاطلاق في
الاعتداء على خطي انابيب
ولا معلومات لديها عما حدث
قال قائد مجموعه فاغن يفقيني بريجوجين في
رد على وزير الدفاع الروسي ان قوه فاغنر
هي من قتلت الاوكرانيين في باخمت واشار
الى ان الاسلحه التي تحتاجها قوته للقتال
في جبهه باخمت لم تصل حتى الان واضاف
بريكوجين انه من المبكر الحديد عما بعد
باخمات لان المعركه مستمره وليست سهله
مشيرا الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه تقاتل
بشراسه في بخمه ولا تستسلم بسهوله وذلك في
رد على تصريحات وزير الدفاع الروسي
شقاق في البيت الواحد اظهرته التصريحه
المتبادله بين السيرشويك وزير الدفاع
الروسي وجيني بريكوجين قائد مجموعه فاجنر
شويغو صرح بان القوات الروسيه قتلت احد
عشر الف جنديا اوكراني حول بخمه خلال
فبراير رد قائد على وزير الدفاع الروسي ان
مجموعته من فعلت ذلك
اعتقد ان وزير الدفاع قيمهم بشكل صحيح لقد
قتلت شركه فاجنر حوالي 11 الف شخص في
فبراير
انتقدت تقليل من شان القوات الاوكرانيه
وطلب قاده روسيا بعدم وصفهم بالجبناء
الاوكرانيون لا يهربون انهم يموتون بشكل
جماعي من اجل باخموت ويستسلمون فقط كملاذ
اخير توقفوا عن وصفهم بالجبناء انهم مثلنا
ونفس الدم يتدفق فيهم
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان رئيس الوزراء
العراقي اكد له ضمان امن القوه الامريكيه
في العراق من جهات غير تابعه للدوله في
اشاره الى الميليشيات المواليه لايران
يجب ان نكون قادرين على العمل بسلامه
وامان لتنفيذ دورنا الحيوي بتقديم المشوره
للقوات العراقيه لذا اود ان اشكر رئيس
الوزراء السوداني ووزير الدفاع العباسي
على التزامهما اليوم بضمان ان قوات
التحالف الموجوده في العراق بطلب عراقي
ستتم حمايتها من العناصر التابعه وغير
التابعه للدوله نركز على مهمه هزيمه داعش
هذا هو هدفنا الوحيد هنا والتهديدات
والهجمات على قواتنا تقوض مهمتنا
التحذير الامريكي لطهران شاركه اخر او اخر
الماني حيث انتقدت وزيره خارجيتها التدخل
الايراني في العراق قائله ان النظام يضع
المنطقه باسرها تحت التهديد
على الدول ان تحترم سياده العراق كما
نتوقع منها ان تحترم سياده كل الدول
الاوروبيه ويظهر النظام الايراني بهجمته
الصاروخيه انه لا يضطهد شعبه بقسوه ووحشيه
فحسب بل يضع حياه الناس والاستقرار في
المنطقه كلها تحت الخطر في سبيل الحفاظ
على قوته وهذا امر غير مقبول وخطير على
المنطقه كامله
قالت ميليشيا حزب الله العراقي انها ليست
ملزمه باي تفهمات بين الاطراف السياسيه
العراقيه والقوات الامريكيه اشارت الى
انها ستهاجم القوات الامريكيه وهي لا
تنتظر الاذن من احد جاء ذلك تعليقا على
زياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي للعراق ولقائه
مع رئيس الوزراء محمد شياع السوداني اليوم
اتهمت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه اسرائيل بشن حرب
مفتوحه على الفلسطينيين بعد اقتحام لمخيم
جنين اسفر عن مقتل سته فلسطينيين بينما
قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه استهدف منفذ
عمليات حواره الثانيه ظهرا تتولى القوات
الخاصه اسرائيليه في شاحنه تجاريه وقوات
كبيره من الجيش الاسرائيلي والطيران
الحربي يحلق فرقها مخيم جنين يحاصرون هذا
المنزل وتبدا المعركه مع من تحصنوا بداخله
للقوات الخاصه ونعادي ثمره المعركه طبعا
ضرب على بيتنا قضيه ان يرجع الاول ثم بدا
اطلاق الصواريخ الكتف على هذا المنزل
علمنا من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي المستدف
منزل جارنا فجلسنا هنا اطلقت 16 قذيفه كتف
هذا الدمار قد يدلل على ان الوضع الميداني
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه معزول تماما عن
الوضع السياسي وسط ضغوط امريكيه واوروبيه
لتهدئه الاوضاع على الارض ترافقها تصريحات
رسميه اسرائيليه بالتزامها بالتهدئه من
مخيم جنين خالد القاسم العربيه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
في فرنسا تظاهرات تخطت المليون شخص
احتجاجا على رفع سن التقاعد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد التقى ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان برئيس مجلس القياده
الرئاسي اليمني رشاد العليمي حيث اكد على
دعم المملكه لجهود التوصل الى حل سياسيا
في اليمن وجرى خلال الاجتماع استعراض
مستجدات الاوضاع على الساحه اليمنيه
وتاكيد على استمرار دعم السعوديه للمجلس
الحكومي للمجلس والحكومه اليمنيه والشعب
اليمني وتاكيد ايضا على دعم كل الجهود
للتواصل لحل سياسي شامل في اليمن برعايه
الامم المتحده لتحقيق الامن والاستقرار
اعلنت وزاره الصحه المصريه عن وفاه اثنين
واصابه سته عشر اخرين جراء حادث او حادث
خروج قطار عن مسار في مدينه قليوب بمحافظه
القليوبيه وافادت وسائل علم المصريه ان
القطار خرج عن مساره في محطه القطار في
المدينه فيما اعلنت النيابه فتحه تحقيق في
الحدث
رحب البيت الابيض باقتراح قانون قدمه عضو
مجلس الشيوخ الديمقراطي مارك
الجمهوريه جون سيون من شانه تمكين
الولايات المتحده من حظر تطبيق تيك توك
المملوك لشركه صينيه واقل مستشار الامن
القوميه ان اقتراح القانون يرمي الى منع
المخاطر الامنيه التي تتهدد التكنولوجيا
المعلومات والاتصالات وشدد سالفا على ان
مشروع القانون الحائز تاييد الحزبين يمكن
او يمكن حكومه الولايات المتحده من منع
حكومه اجنبيه من استغلال خدمات تكنولوجيه
بطريقه تعرض بيانات حساسه لامريكيين
والامن القومي لمخاطر اما السنه فقد حذر
في بيان من ان تيك توك يعزز من قدرات
الصين على المراقبه وتسهيل حملات تاثير
تاثير خبيثه في الولايات المتحده ويعزز
اقتراح القانون اقتراح القانون المطروح
على مجلس الشيوخ الزخ م السياسي ضد تيك
توك الذي يستهدفه ايضا تشريع منفصل مطروح
على مجلس النواب
في فرنسا تظاهر اكثر من 1.2 مليون شخص
احتجاجا على مشروع قانوني اصلاح نظام
التقاعد هذا ويعد هذا تحرك امتدادا
لتحركات سابقه اخرى حدثت خلال الشهرين
الماضيين
اسبوع حاسم تعيشه فرنسا في ظل معركه قانون
التقاعد ثماني نقابات عماليه دعت الى
تظاهرات مليونيه واضراب تحت عنوان اغلاق
فرنسا ياتي ذلك بالتزامن مع دراسه مجلس
الشيوخ لمشروع القانون لمواجهه ذلك حشدت
السلطات الاف عناصر الشرطه انتشروا في
شوارع العاصمه بشكل خاص ولكن ايضا في معظم
المدن الفرنسيه حيث سجل خروج 260 تظاهره
لكن ذلك لم يمنع من وقوع اشتباكات بين
المتظاهرين والشرطه استخدمت الاخيره
خلالها الغاز المسيل للدموع ووقعت بعض
الاصابات في صفوف المتظاهرين ويشمل
الاضراب قطاعات كثيره من بينها الصحه
والتعليم والمواصلات والطاقه حيث سجل
مشاركه نحو اربعين في المئه من المدرسين
بهذا الاضراب في حين الغت هيئه الطيران
المدني ما بين 20 الى 30% من رحلات
الطيران واثر ذلك على رحلات الطيران
والقطارات بين فرنسا وبريطانيا بشكل خاص
النقابات تسعى لان يتواصل الاضراب لايام
عديده وذلك بهدف ايقاف فرنسا وشل اقتصادها
من اجل اجبار الحكومه على التراجع فجدهوك
العربيه باريس
في كوريا الجنوبيه تفاصيل جديده تتكشف عن
عدد اطفال زعيم البلاد كيم جون والتي ظلت
لسنين طويله مجهوله حيث كشفت الاستخبارات
في سيول عن معلومات مهمه تتعلق بمن
نتابعهم في هذا التقرير
استخبارات سيول تكشف حقائق جديده عن حياه
زعيم كوريا الشماليه الذي لطالما اخفاها
عن وسائل الاعلام واعين شعبه ايضا جدل
كبير سببه هذه المره اطفال كيم جونغ اون
صاحب الاستعراضات النوويه الاستخبارات
كشفت عن عدد ابناء الزعيم ثلاثه اولاد
البكر ذكر والثانيه انثى والثالث لم يحدد
اوسطهم ابنته كيمجو اي التي ظهرت معه في
اكثر من مناسبه اخرها عندما تم اختبار
الصواريخ الباليستيه العابره للقارات وهي
خطوه تنذر باحتمال انتقال الزعامه لجيل
رابع من عائلتكيم وفقا للمشرعين الذين
اطلعتهم المخابرات الوطنيه الكوريه
الجنوبيه على المعلومات فان البنت الثانيه
التي باتت رفيقه والدها لم يتم رصد اسمها
في ايه مؤسسه تعليميه وانها تت تعليمها من
المنزل وصدر مرسوم بمنع المواطنين من
تسميه اسمها ومن له اسمها قبل ولادتها
عليه ان يغيره لكن اطفال كيما الاول
والثالثه لم يروا علنا ابدا وليس هناك اي
دليل مفصل عنهم سوى ان اول طفل له ولد في
عام 2010 وسط انباء انه يعاني من مشاكل
جسديه وعقليه لم يتم تاكيدها بسبب الرقابه
الصارمه والمعلومه الوحيده ان الطفل
الثالث ولد في فبراير 2017 وعمره الان ست
سنوات تقريبا وفق مراقبين كوريا الشماليه
تعتبر دوله مغلقه بشكل كبير عن البلدان
الاخرى ومن الصعب التحقق من المعلومات
المتعلقه بمجتمعها وحكومتها وخاصه عن
الرئيس وعائلته
[تصفيق]
هذه النشره الى العناوين
الاتحاد الاوروبي يطالب ايران بالتوضيح
سبب العثور على اثار يورانيوم على التخصيب
ويعتبره تطورا غير مسبوق
بعد واشنطن تحقيق الماني يكشف عن تورط
فريق كوماندوز اوكرانيا في تفجير نوت
والبيت الابيض يرحب باقتراح قانون يتيح
حظر تيك توك ضمن مشروع قرار يستهدف شركات
التكنولوجيا الصينيه
اشكركم حسن متابعه مشاهدينا والقاكم بعد
دقائق الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]